ça veut dire que quand on démarre
l'examen de votre projet de loi et quand
on le lit on doit savoir ce que chacun
dans le nouveau système percevra comme
retraite
c'est ça la définition or dans le
système actuel
ça n'est pas le cas personne ne comprend
et ne sait combien il touchera plus -
vraisemblablement moins avec le nouveau
système
je prends un exemple votre fameux alors
c'est le nouvel acronyme à la mode à la
mode leur matt leur mat
tout le monde connaît leur match le
revenu moyen d'activités par tête leur
maths ça manquait ça manquait voilà ce
nouvel indicateur qui est absolument
essentiel si j'en crois votre texte
personne ne sait comment il va être
défini mais mme palin s'est donc on
navigue à vue
et si on veut éviter demain et c'est
l'objectif de chacun d'entre nous à
gauche et sûrement bien au delà d'avoir
contrairement à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui un tour de retraités pauvres
dans ce pays relativement bas eh bien il
faut sûrement pas adopté le texte tel
qu'il est merci cher collègue monsieur
bazin
merci madame est présente mais si les
ministres mes chers collègues c'est vrai
que cette cet alinéa pose question si on
reprend cette rédaction un objectif de
garanties de niveau de vie satisfaisant
ou retraités franchement on est entre
nous on est là pour faire la loi
certes c'était cet article n'aura pas de
portée normative mais il fit que les
objectifs du futur système et et on est
en train d'avancer parce que pour
avancer il faut quand même fixé bien les
objectifs et très clairement vous dites
monsieur le ministre il ne faut pas
chercher à inquiéter v la rédaction
inquiète
pourquoi votre réforme inquiète parce
qu'elle n'est pas financé pourquoi votre
réforme inquiète parce que votre usine à
point multiplie les variables
aujourd'hui il ya deux variables
on passa quatre variables dans le futur
système vous parler de liberté mais en
fait c'est une fausse liberté c'est
celle qui appauvrit vous savez quand
aujourd'hui dans le système actuel on
est libre de partir plus tôt sans décote
je pense à ces mères de familles qui
peuvent partir à 62 ans sans décote dans
le futur système
elles partiront avec décote avec décote
pourquoi votre réforme inquiète vous
essayer de rassurer à chaque fois
oralement par des promesses orales
mais ces promesses orales on ne les
retrouve pas dans le texte au futur
article
pourquoi votre réforme inquiète monsieur
le président de la commission aux
affaires économiques
parce qu'on a regardé depuis deux ans et
demi ce que vous faites aux retraités
vous avez fait là des pensions comment
on peut vous faire confiance c'est
normal qu'on doute de votre est formel
si monsieur bénin monsieur petit
merci madame la présidente vous chers
collègues moi je suis ravi de revenir
dimanche matin pour se poser la question
si la france doit dire que c'est
identique ou égales et qu'on arrête
qu'on ait rassemblé là la représentation
nationale pour ce genre de débats
extrêmement important sur le mot
identiques ou le mot égal alors on nous
a traité d' amateurs et bricoleurs
je rappelle quand même qu'on a les bancs
de la gauche qui ont voté au scrutin
public que la france voulait un système
inéquitable
nous on ira jusqu'au bout nous on ira
jusqu'au bout alors j'y viens maintenant
à cette amende
je viens maintenant à cet amendement
vous nous demandez de m dans l'article
dans l'article 1
vous nous demandez de mettre un chiffre
est un seul 75 % mais je vous rappelle
que à l'article 8 et à l'article 9
alinéa 7 vous aurez vos réponses et
c'est là qu'elles doivent être elles
doivent pas être dans l'article 1
parce que quand vous marquez ça dans
l'article 1 et je vous rappelle qu'on
définit qui doit qui va le faire quand
est-ce que ça va être fait comment ça va
être fait et ce n'est pas la
représentation dieu du parlement qui va
le faire c'est bien la c1 et russes et
bien les partenaires sociaux et c'est
normal c'est ce qu'avait décidé ambroise
croizat
et quand vous mettez un chiffre dans le
1 1 75% taux de remplacement
je vous rappelle que de façon à réduire
les inégalités ou retraite
nous avons exclu les les salaires
supérieurs à 120 mille euros nous les
avons exclu de l'assurance comment
voulez vous être logique et comment
voulez-vous dire que on va réduire les
inégalités si vous mettez un pourcentage
messieurs de la gauche qui c'est qui
individualise le système avec des
chiffres pareils
[Applaudissements]
merci mme la présidente sur le fondement
de l'article sans ligne à 5 mais je
petit moi je suis d'accord avec vous je
partage votre analyse vous ne dites on
en débattra l'article 6 7 etc
mais ma crainte c'est qu'on atteigne
jamais ses articles
c'est ça la difficulté c'est ça la
difficulté et vous comprenez qu'à partir
du moment où on n'est pas sûr de les
atteindre ces articles il est légitime
que pose la question temps peut encore
le faire quand on peut encore le faire à
l'occasion d'articles leur dos monsieur
petit les seydoux nous exprimer puisque
nous vous nous vous ne garantissait pas
que nous atteindrons ne serait-ce que
l'article 5
merci cher collègue monsieur dans les
villes
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre vous nous dites n'inquiétait
pas les gens inutilement et c'est que
c'est pas nous qui les inquiète ont ils
sont déjà qu'un très très inquiet parce
que d'abord il vous connaissent ça c'est
la première chose ça fait deux ans et
demi qui qui vous voit à l'oeuvre
et puis la deuxième chose c'est que la
réforme est l'ami quand même vous l'avez
vu toute une partie du pays dans la rue
et donc les gens sont effectivement très
inquiet donc monsieur le ministre
rassure et nous et monsieur le
rapporteur tout à l'air vient d'indiquer
que voilà on arriverait à peu près
avez-vous dit au même ordre de grandeur
70 75 % avez-vous dit un jour je ne
trahis pas vos propos nous on vous
propose de sanctuariser l'idée que ça
sera au moins 75%
je pense que si c'est ce que vous
prévoyez ça vous coûte rien de
l'inscrire dans cet article ou en fixe
effectivement des objectifs et moi je
suis pas d'accord je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire notre
collègue le furent sur le sujet je pense
que cet objectif doit être inscrit dès
l'article 1er ensuite effectivement il
ya des mécanismes qui permettent de
garantir ou pas les objectifs que nous
fixons c'est la logique de votre loi moi
je m'inscris dans cette logique là donc
je vous propose d'inscrire un objectif
réel pas un objectif fumée dans cet
article 1er on me dit vous faites de
l'affichage
alors si nous on fait de l'affichage
vous faites quoi vous franchement si cet
article c'est un article dont il est
avéré pour vous c'est un article
d'affichage donc affichant des choses
sérieuses et ensuite essayons
effectivement de les mettre en oeuvre
ensuite monsieur le ministre vous
critiquer nos références je vous
confirme qu'on n'a pas les mêmes verrait
référence vous vous référez vous à
l'étude d'impact moi je me réfère à des
travaux d'économistes en l'occurrence
stéphane peu à citer henri sterdyniak
économiste extrêmement sérieux vous en
contester les analyses ça serait
intéressant d'en discuter avec lui
d'ailleurs on l'avait invité à
l'assemblée nationale pour se faire il
ya quelques jours de cela
je reprends le tableau vous nous avez
indiqué qu'ils aient à la page 182 et je
lis qui a écrit au dessus et j'aimerais
une précision monsieur le ministre
au dessus de ce tableau il est écrit
parce que tout le monde explique en tout
cas parmi les gens auxquels nous
accordons crédit que les pensions vont
effectivement baissé d'au moins 20%
il est inscrit ceux ci les pensions
servies par le système de retraite
seront en moyenne plus élevée dans le
système universel c'est vous qui dites
je sais pas moi je termine plus élevé
dans le système universel que dans le
système actuel en raison notamment d'un
âge moyen de départ plus élevé à la
suite de la réforme en raison d'un âge
moyen de départ plus élevé à la suite de
la réforme préciser un peu tout ça ça
nous intéresse
madame favre l'île madame la présidente
bon vous organiser un débat qui n'a ni
queue ni tête
donc là effectivement dans l'article
vous mettez des chiffres ça n'a rien à y
faire on est dans l'article et des
principes généraux donc ça on sait très
bien que ce type là d'information les
75%
ça doit être discuté au niveau de
l'article 7 et 8 on passe notre temps à
discuter de remplacement de jamais
plutôt que pas non mais c'est pas
sérieux chers collègues ce n'est pas
sérieux et d'autre part vous passez
votre temps à divulguer de fausses
informations
alors je vais essayer de remettre les
pendules à l'heure donc monsieur bazin
quand vous dites qu'on peut partir sans
décote
aujourd'hui quand on est une mère de
famille mais demain aussi on peut partir
sans décote quand on est une mère de
famille une mère de famille à un enfant
elle aura 5 % de majoration
donc si elle presse il veut utiliser ces
5 % pour partir un an plus tôt elle le
pourra une mère de famille qui aura deux
enfants elle pourra partir deux ans plus
tôt donc vous voyez bien qu'on peut
partir sans décote sauf qu on pourra
aussi faire le choix d'avoir une pension
majorée et aujourd'hui ça c'est pas
possible
donc ça c'est la première fois fausse
information que je voulais démentir
deuxième phase informations pour madame
dumont qui s'en va peut-être qu'elle va
pouvoir quand même écouter cette réponse
l'insee et le nouvel indicateur le
nouvel indicateur c'est tout à fait de
la capacité de la compétence de l'insee
de le mettre en place l'autorité de la
statistique a justement recadrer les
syndicats en disant qu'il ne devait pas
faire de propagande dans le cadre de
leur travail et que c'était tout à fait
la compétence
ceux de l'insee de mettre en place à cet
indicateur est que ça ne posait aucun
problème technique donc encore une
fausse information que je veux démentir
ici c'est dans un article du figaro
d'hier ou d'avant-hier troisième phase
informations le niveau de vie le niveau
de pension satisfaisant vous nous faites
tous croire que ce niveau n'existe pas
mais niveau de pension satisfaisant
aujourd'hui c'est le droit actuel
utilise ce terme que ce soit dans le
code de la sécu pour décrire le système
de retraite où que ce soit dans la
charte européenne
donc ce terme de niveau de vie
satisfaisant existe c'est pas nous qui
l'avons inventé on le reprend pourquoi
parce qu'on se situe dans la continuité
de la retraite actuel par rapport à
notre ambition comme on l'a déjà rappelé
les retraités actuels sont beaucoup
moins pauvres que les actifs actuels et
on peut s'en féliciter
et on veut continuer dans ce sens là la
parole est à monsieur coquerel bien la
présidente chers collègues je vais
profiter d'un ordre cette intervention
pour saluer la victoire écrasante de
bernie sanders au nevada ce qui à mon
avis est qu'une promesse une meilleure
promesse que la loi que à laquelle vous
nous imposez débattre et attendait chers
collègues je suis libre de ma parole si
ça vous dérange pas d'accord arrêtez
braille et comme vous le faites depuis
maintenant deux jours à chaque fois que
quelqu'un parle mais bien sûr bien sûr
c'est ce que vous faites bien merci
merci même la présidente tient
merci de préciser dans le calme c'est
donc je revenais à ce que disait tout à
l'heure la réponse du ministre a chip ce
qui est du rapporteur parce que
j'entends donc monsieur pitre à chelsea
vous nous dites en gros bas à quoi sert
le taux de remplacement 75 % du taux de
remplacement et cetera
puisque nous nous proposons 85% du smic
bien vous oubliez de dire que age 2 des
parts égales
vous proposez 85% du smic comme palier
mais à des gens qui partiront plus tard
toujours plus tard et dac et confère
d'ailleurs l'article votre article 10
puisqu'on demande d'aller concrètement
là dessus où on parle bien d'un âge
déquilibre qu'en plus les gens ne
connaîtront pas au départ de la carrière
ni même au milieu
carrière donc en réalité vous mélanger
plusieurs choses ne serait-ce que vous
mélangez le fait que des gens
aujourd'hui qu'ils partent avec un
revenu une pension de retraite qui
correspond à un taux de remplacement
dans l'avenir ils partir au plus tard
sans savoir exactement à quel moment ils
pourront partir c'est évidemment des
choses totalement différentes d'ailleurs
monsieur turquois vous notez vous dit
tout à l'heure que finalement ça sera à
peu près la même valeur qui sera
consacrée du pipe par rapport aux
retraités donc pourquoi s'inquiéter sauf
que cette valeur que vous consacrerez là
aussi vous la consacrerez toujours plus
tard pour les gens qui partiront à la
retraite c'est le fondement de votre
article 10 qui prévoit que en fonction
de l'espérance de vie du nombre de
retraités partir en même temps etc etc
et bien les gens qui partent aujourd'hui
avec une valeur tant partiront à
l'avenir à 65 66 67 68 ans on en
reparlera l'article 10
donc vous ne parlez pas de la même chose
vous ne parlez pas de la même chose
tous les groupes qui l'ont souhaité ont
pu s'exprimer
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin
à
[Musique]
il ya près des sous-amendements avant où
il ya des bonnes amendement est
je vais donc mettre aux voix les
amendements 26 836 est identique
le scrutin est ouvert et équivalents
merci monsieur petit pour cette
précision
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votants 87
exprimé 76 majorité 39 pour 7 contre 69
l'amendement 26 836 est identique est
rejetée
n
[Musique]
je veux mettre aux voix le
sous-amendement 40 2158 avec avis
défavorable qui et pour qui et contre le
42 1162 même avis qui est pour et qui
est contre
alors pour
monsieur monsieur peu pour pour la
clarté du débat donc l'amendement que je
viens de mettre au revoir c'était de
remplacer la première phrase de l'alinéa
4 substituer aux mots correspondant le
mot équivalent donc je mets aux voix
l'amendement le sous-amendement quarante
deux mille cent soixante où il faut
substituer aux mots annuel les mots
chaque année donc je mets cet amendement
au revoir qui et pour qui est content
il est rejeté alors je crois que vous
avez retrouvé le fil donc je mets aux
voileux 40 259 qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est rejeté le 42 163 qui est cours
qui est contre il est rejeté
le 42 161 qui est pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté je mets aux voix leuven
c'est le truc c'est sur les écrans qu'il
faut regarder c'est pas sur les
tablettes pour le oui au moment du vote
chers collègues si vous pouvez alors un
petit pois techniques au moment du vote
je vous demande de regarder les écrans
et sûre sur les tablettes
n'hésitez pas à appuyer sur les flèches
pour revenir en arrière vu le nombre
d'amendements identiques donc c'était
c'était la minute technique
je mets au voilà maintenant 24 637 de
madame ménard avec avis défavorable qui
et pour qui est content il est rejeté
[Musique]
je mets aux voix les amendements 24 1638
est identique avec avis défavorable
eh bien
on va une affiche ou pas
à
eh bien je partage votre avis allons
rythme de la technique
alors expliquez lui que la tablette elle
est par défaut alors messieurs benoît
pour un apprentissage du fonctionnement
de la tablette le la tablette se place
toujours sur le dernier amendement
donc vous pouvez remonter donc je mets
ouvrez les 24 6 138 est identique et
pour qui est contre il sent rejetée
monsieur benoit pour un rappel au
règlement
merci marin présidente comme je vous
apprécie et je sais que c'est réciproque
je voulais je voulais non non non
sérieusement même la présidente et je le
dis pour les techniciens pour la
distraction avec un certain nombre de
collègues on our ses forces comme le
fond l'ensemble des députés de suivre
sur la tablette
la lecture des amendements soit on les
suit de manière individuelle en cliquant
sur les flèches rien ne se passe soit ça
se fait automatiquement en appuyant en
bas à gauche et dans ce cas là on à le
dérouler automatique et depuis à bella à
l'instant voyez aller sans non non non
non non non mais ça fait attendait ça
fait ça fait une demi heure ça fait une
demi heure que nous étions bloqués sur
l'amendement de monsieur jumelles le 26
1997 ça fait une demi-heure de moi je
veux bien
je veux bien mais il faut il faut que la
technique quand même s'efforce de nous
faciliter la tâche si possible merci
madame la présidente
oui merci chers collègues
monsieur le ministre suspension de
séance pour cinq minutes
la séance s'est reprise
je suis saisi de demandes de scrutins
publics sur les amendements 458 est
identique le sous-amendement 40 2150 les
amendements 26 1856 est identique par le
groupe gdr ces scrutins sont annoncées
dans l'ensemble de l'assemblée nationale
alors le 458 madame du biez merci madame
la présidente
cet amendement en fait a pour objet de
préciser en fait ce qu est le niveau de
vie des retraités puisque dans le texte
on parle d'un niveau de vie satisfaisant
sauf que satisfaisant c'est une rue une
dimension très relative et nous ce que
nous souhaitons c'est de remplacer le
mot satisfaisant aux retraités par des
retraités comparable à celui actifs
c'est-à-dire un niveau de vie des
retraités comparable à celui des actifs
et donc par cet amendement nous avons
deux objectifs à la fois empêcher que
les retraités ne sombre dans une sorte
d'une carrière précaires se retrouve
avec des pensions trop faible et en même
temps qu'il peut effectivement ça assure
une garantie pour l'ensemble des
retraités de nous d'avoir un taux de
remplacement qui soit correct je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup chers collègues le 25 49
le 25 49 peut-être madame du monde
je
oui il y avait peut-être les
sous-amendement d'abord lors des vols
lui fassiez non 25 euros
oui donc la maman va c'est toujours de
garantir le niveau de vie des retraités
pour qu'on puisse l'apprécier
comparativement à des des actifs parce
qu'il ya la question du niveau de vie
satisfaisant
je n'y reviens pas et c'est à dire
prévisible lisible qui sont les deux
adjectifs qui colle le moins avec ce
projet de loi est donc s'il ya pas de
prévisibilité de lisibilité et bien le
niveau de vie satisfaisant n'est par
définition pas possible a atteint et
puis les à la question du rapport
effectivement entre revenus et retraite
et ce rapport là il faut bien le
quantifier et aujourd'hui on nage en
plein brouillard
beaucoup l'ont dit et donc pour toutes
ces raisons là nous voulons inscrire
dans la loi des retraités comparable à
celui des actifs
merci merci cher collègue monsieur le
président le furent pour la clarté des
débats on appelle les amendements avant
les sous-amendement mais bientôt vous
serez à nouveau à la présidence le 42100
ce monsieur le président le furent pour
en laisser le règlement sous-amendement
sont appelés après l'amendement qu'ils
amendent sans ça ça n'a pas de sens il
convient donc d'appeler l'amendement les
sous-amendement la série de
sous-amendements après le propos de
madame dubié c'est c'est là le principe
constant
pas n'importe et pimpant merci monsieur
le président le furent votre tour
viendra vite le 42500 peut-être madame
valentin elle est pas là non le quart en
2005 sans le sou avant d'en 42500 n'est
pas défendu le sous-amendement 40 2150
oui messieurs dames i merci madame la
présidente bon on a régulièrement qui
viennent pimenter nos échanges quelques
interventions d'une majorité un peu
calimero qui est un peu vexé de ne pas
pouvoir diriger les débats comme elle
l'entend mais c'est ainsi et donc nous
avons effectivement déposé un certain
nombre d'amendements qui nous permettent
si vous écoutez bien ce que nous disons
de défendre un certain nombre d'idées de
propositions d'argumenter d'interroger
le ministre c'est l'essentiel de nos
interventions et vous pouvez le
reprendre pouvait leur lire après si
vous n'avez pas bien tout entendu voilà
donc ici à plusieurs propositions dans
ces sous-amendements que je devais
défendre de manière groupée madame la
présidente pour vous être agréable qui
vous font plusieurs propositions puisque
vous les refuser tout donc on essaye
plusieurs mots pour voir lequel pour
éventuellement vous agrée correctement
donc la continuité du niveau de vie et
pour nous
un élément essentiel et la parité du
niveau de vie entre les actifs et les
retraités est une dimension que nous
voulons garantir et nous vous proposons
d'en faire un des objectifs avec madame
du bief de 2,7 de cet article je veux
pour clarifier également par rapport à
ce qu'a dit monsieur le rapporteur tout
à leur dire qu'effectivement nous
suggérions que le taux de remplacement
soit de manière générale au minimum de
75%
mais qui dit un plafond à un plancher et
que ce plancher soit à 100 % du smic
ce qui est assez différent de ce que de
ce que vous proposez nous pensons que
ces objectifs aurait pu effectivement
être indiquée dans cet article 1er merci
beaucoup chers collègues sur les votes
des sous-amendements 42 1347 je suis
saisi par le groupe l'est républicain
d'une demande de scrutin public le
scrutin est annoncée dans l'enceinte de
l'assemblée nationale le 42 1347
monsieur le président le fur merci
madame la présidente
moi je souhaite que le mot travail
apparaissent comme l'une des conditions
du calcul la retraite d'où mon
sous-amendement la retraite c'est la
conséquence du travail
c'est un salaire différé il ya des
évidences qu'il faut rappeler et je vais
vous poser à cette occasion monsieur le
ministre
un cas très précis il s'agit d'une un
gel cas très précis que je connais bien
une jeune femme qui rentrait aux
hôpitaux de paris comme agent
hospitalier
elle est devenue aide soignante elle est
devenue infirmière et elle poursuit sa
progression elle finie affirme hier
général aux hôpitaux de paris c'est à
dire l'interlocuteur l'interlocutrice en
l'espèce du chef de service aujourd'hui
cette jeune femme a pris sa retraite
mais c'est la même chose pour celle qui
prend sa retraite aujourd'hui sa
retraite est calculée en fonction son
ultime à 10 des six derniers mois
infirmière général elle et elle finit
hors classe hors classe à demain sa
retraite sera calculée non pas sur son
dernier indice
mais sur l'ensemble de sa carrière elle
a été partiellement être soignante elle
a été partiellement agence pitallier
elle a été partiellement infirmières et
a été partiellement infirmières général
c'est à dire que son run niveau de
retraite va baisser
peut-être même de moitié monsieur le
ministre si c'est ça c'est exactement ça
vous finissez à un niveau très élevé de
la fonction publique on vous calcule
votre retraite
et là on va vous calculer sa part
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente
moi je ne peux pas travailler dans ces
conditions c'est précisément parce que
ma question est pertinente qu'il ya tous
boire l'art monsieur le ministre je
souhaiterais que vous m'indiquiez très
précisément la différence entre les deux
niveaux de retraite
dans ces deux cas de figure concernant
deux personnes qui ont terminé leur
itinéraire professionnel comme
infirmière général à l'assistance
publique de paris le 30 7178 n'est pas
défendu le 39 32 madame ménard
merci madame la présidente
le livre la notion de niveau de vie
satisfaisant est floue on l'a déjà
expliqué à plusieurs reprises depuis
hier soir satisfaisante pour qui par
rapport à quoi
il vaudrait mieux lui substituer un
autre terme le terme des 100 par exemple
le reflet des revenus perçus durant la
vie active devant être fondée sur des
critères objectifs
je vous rappelle que le mouvement des
gilet jaune n'était pas sur les
ronds-points uniquement pour une
question de taxes sur le carburant sur
ces ronds-points on trouvait aussi de
nombreux retraités dont niveau de vie
s'est terriblement dégradée depuis trois
ans notamment sous l'effet de la hausse
de la csg et tend à s'éloigner du niveau
de vie des actifs
je vous rappelle le double coup dur que
vous leur avait déjà imposé
monsieur macron trouvait en effet
anormal d'augmenter de 1,7 point
la csg des retraités aisés
c'est à dire pour le président de la
république 1200 euros par mois avant de
devoir faire marche arrière toute quand
il s'est rendu compte des défis des
difficultés matérielles dans lesquelles
il avait
longer tout ce qui touchait des petites
retraites s'en est suivie la
désindexation des retraites sur
l'inflation deuxième punition
bref on peut dire que vous ne les aimez
pas beaucoup de retraités qu'ils ont
raison de se méfier de votre réforme
alors encore une fois ce n'est pas un
cadeau que l'on fait à nos retraités
c'est une juste rétribution du travail
de toute une vie
je vous remercie madame la présidente
merci chers collègues
alors monsieur peu pour les amendements
26 856 est identique
oui merci madame la présidente alors je
sais que certains ici s'agace sur les
amendements qui porte sur des
remplacements de mots mais là il s'agit
de remplacer le mot satisfaisant qui est
une notion vous l'avouerez qu'est
relativement flou gazeuse avec le mot de
dignité et je vous rappelle parce que je
sais que le nouveau monde n'aime pas
trop les références historiques mais que
la dignité est une notion qui existe
dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen de 1948 et qui est
un texte auquel on peut légitimement se
référer ici me semble-t-il et je le cite
d'ailleurs dans cette déclaration
universelle en de 48 des droits de
l'homme reconnaît que tous les êtres
humains possède une dignité inhérente et
qu'ils naissent libres et égaux en
droits et en dignité
c'est là les déclarations des droits de
l'homme de 1948 or aujourd'hui dans
notre pays il y à des retraités des
retraités qui dorment dans des voitures
dans le froid sur les 9 millions de
pauvres de notre pays plus d'un million
sont des retraités et vous faites une
réforme qui va aggraver cette situation
en refusant
de fixer une rémunération digne on
retrouve le mot en refusant les plafonds
qui vous ont été suggérés en reculant
l'âge déquilibre et en ignorant la
pénibilité et les carrières longues donc
la question de mettre dans cet article
enquête un article de principe la
question de la dignité en se référant à
la déclaration des droits de l'homme de
1948 nous paraît extrêmement important
merci chers collègues de 38,85 madame
verner
pardon madame la présidente j'étais
quelque peu troublée par le président
alors donc c'est un amendement c'est un
amendement d'appel qui vise à assurer à
l'ensemble des retraités de notre pays
que leur niveau de vie reste une réelle
priorité
alors c'est vrai actuellement dans le
texte que nous étudions
c'est une affirmation qui tient avant
tout du cadre de cette loi mais je
souhaitais réaffirmer ici que la
réindexation progressive de toutes les
pensions de retraite au niveau de
l'inflation jamais réalisé jusqu'ici est
un acte marqueur de la volonté de cette
majorité
mais il nous faudra bien sûr aller plus
loin donc cet amendement d'appel encore
une fois loin d'être symbolique rappelle
que la dignité du niveau de vie
satisfaisant de nos retraités est une
exigence que nous n'oublions pas je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues le 42 1340
monsieur coquerel
je reviens sur cette notion de
satisfaisant ou manifestement la
majorité le gouvernement 10 mai au on
comprend pas votre réaction quoi cette
évidence que ce qui est satisfaisant
le problème c'est que depuis deux ans
vous êtes arrivé au pouvoir
le côté satisfaisant varie beaucoup
selon l'échelle des richesses dans ce
pays par exemple vous avez trouvé
satisfaisant manifestement sur les
chiffres que les 5 % des français les
plus riches se voit accorder 25% du gain
du pouvoir d'achat au sol depuis deux
ans al'inverse par exemple que les 5%
les plus modestes l'an prochain verront
leurs revenus disponibles diminué de 45
euros
on voit bien que c'est une logique assez
assez curieuse que cette leçon de
satisfaction satisfaisant manifestement
vous avez prouvé qu'ils avaient trop
d'appels distribués aux plus défavorisés
satisfaisant manifestement vous allez
trouver que il était normal de sortir
des statistiques du chômage qui vous
arrangent après pour chanter victoire
sur le front de l'emploi
tous ceux qui sont des travailleurs très
partielle dans ce pays etc etc
autrement dit non pour vous fais pas
confiance sur sept niveaux de
satisfaisant parce que la satisfaction
de ce que vous avez depuis deux ans ces
deux gaves et les plus riches de ce pays
au détriment quasiment de tout le reste
des français et notamment des plus
pauvres donc c'est bien pour ça que ces
amendements sont évidemment nécessaires
la dignité c'est quelque chose
effectivement manqué mon collègue
stéphane peu l'adie qui est
compréhensible qui fait partie des
déclarations droits de l'homme
la satisfaction pour vous c'est de
satisfaire toujours les plus riches
merci chers collègues le 42 1341
monsieur coquerel madame fiat
merci madame la présidente par cet
amendement nous souhaitons ajouter le
mot au moins respectable d'un
dans ce projet de loi là on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas prendre le risque de se
dire que la moindre personne pourrait se
retrouver
pauvre et avec moins qu'elle ne pouvait
toucher actuellement on vous prend
beaucoup d'exemples on essaye de vous
prouver par a plus b que ce soit sur ses
bancs là où sur les banc d'en face
l'exemple de monsieur le furent était
effectivement un très bon exemple
on a bien du mal à vous faire entendre
raison mais des gens vont perdre avec
votre réforme donc pour quelques
personnes qui vont gagner beaucoup vont
perdre
d'où ces amendes ou tous ces sous
amendements pour faire en sorte
oui on vous essayez de démissionner au
bout
non elle n'a pas ie gay au bout d'une
semaine je pense que les gens ne se
rendent pas compte
on a l'impression quand on parle qu'à
deux ou trois ça fait pas beaucoup mais
deux ou trois fois 26 a fait beaucoup de
bruit
bon s'il vous plaît nous écoutons madame
fiat dans le calme qui à mes yeux
régnait je vous en prie je vous en prie
poursuivez donc nous souhaitons que
toute personne dans notre pays puisse
toucher une pension de retraite
respectable d'où ce sous-amendement bon
merci beaucoup chers collègues le 42 353
monsieur le président le fut
merci valorisante notre souci c'est de
ne pas défavoriser ceux qui ont fait des
efforts de promotion qui ont commencé à
un niveau modeste qui en progresser leur
progression
c'est la leur mais c'est aussi celle de
la société et on a besoin de ces gens là
mon souci c'est de défendre d'ouvriers
qui est devenu contremaître le
contremaître qui poursuivant son
ascension est devenu cadre aujourd'hui
puisqu'il est dans le système privé on
tient compte des 25 meilleures années
avec votre système on va tenir compte
des quarante trois années puisque
système de points implique l'intégralité
de la carrière
ce qui fait qu'on va ramener les gens à
leur condition d'origine votre système
c'est l'ancien régime on ramène les gens
là où ils étaient au départ on ramène
les gens là où ils ont commencé
tu as commencé petit
tu finiras petit même si tu as fait des
efforts de promotion même si tu as fait
des efforts de progression j'ai cité
l'exemple de l'agent spitalier qui est
devenu aide-soignante qui est devenue
infirmière qui est devenue infirmière
général que devient telle j'attends des
réponses de votre part ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que vous nier ces
progressions or nous y avons tous
atterrés à ces progressions et notre
sensibilité gaulliste c'est de favoriser
ces progressions sociale elle concourt
au succès de notre société et votre
système
[Applaudissements]
merci d'écouter monsieur le prix dans le
futur avec un calme granitique
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur sur tous ses amendements
4-4 ils sont dans leur merci madame la
présidente donc on est sur des
amendements qui peu ou prou relève de
ceux qui ont été débattus le pré
précédemment quelques quelques quelques
précisions sur des éléments compte
évoquer donc que moi sincèrement je suis
pas sûr que remplacer le mot
satisfaisant par dignité ou par
respectable va plus rassurer nos
concitoyens parce que je vais avoir une
retraite au niveau respectable je pense
que ça peut faire peur un certain nombre
donc sur des éléments qui ont été
évoqués je pense avant le précédent vote
par monsieur bazin sur aujourd'hui vous
avez quatre variables c'est compliqué
que ça mais aujourd'hui peu ou prou
quand on regarde tous les régimes
c'est à peu près le nombre de variables
qui a parce qu'il ya un taux de service
si un nombre de trimestres ya un âge de
départ sauf qu'elle a froid 42 donc si
on fait ne serait ce que trois variables
x 42 ça fait 120 situations possibles
suivant que vous soyez dans un régime
puis dans l'autre ça peut compliquer
beaucoup beaucoup les choses donc notre
système certes à quatre variables c4
c'est quatre indicateurs comme sur un
tableau de bord clairement à la main des
partenaires sociaux pour piloter plus
finement possible pour avoir la conduite
la plus souple pour tenir compte des
évolutions et puis vous parler de la
répartition monsieur coquerel vous
parler de la répartition est fermé à la
base il me semble que vous êtes
profondément attachés comme nous
d'ailleurs un système de répartition et
le principe du système par répartition
c'est bien les cotisations d'aujourd'hui
qui paye les pensions d'aujourd'hui on
la vit dans une proportion cotisations
pour trois quarts et inter de solidarité
nationale pour les éléments de
solidarité est donc le principal élément
de ce système là c'est quand même les
cotisations et qui dit cotisation 10
masse salariale 10 emplois et donc quand
on travaille sur les politiques de
l'emploi
c'est là assurément la meilleure façon
d'assurer des retraites de plus haut
niveau pour pour
pour nos retraités c'est la masse la
masse salariale d'un côté et de l'autre
côté de le rapport actif sur salariés
actifs sur pardon sur pensionnés qui est
déterminant et donc le une fois qu'on a
ces éléments à l'esprit puisque c'est
quelque chose de finalement d'assez
mathématiques et bien nos par les
partenaires sociaux qui seront en charge
de la cni rue pourront piloter de le là
encore avec en prenant les décisions qui
sont les plus à même de résoudre cette
équation
enfin monsieur le fur monsieur le furent
nous nous interroge sur les progressions
de carrière et je crois que là encore
nous sommes tous à attacher à
l'ascenseur social est évidemment que le
le système par points reflète aussi
cette progression sociale parce que qui
dit petit salaire dit moins de points
que grand salaire alors effectivement
effectivement le système où on retient
les dernières les dernières années peut
sembler apparemment plus favorable mais
on est bien sûr sensible à la
progression de carrière mais on est on
est sensible aussi à ce que à ce que
tout le monde soit intégrée là dedans et
je vais prendre si je je prends la suite
de vos exemples allez on est enfant
d'une famille modeste mais on est une
famille modeste qui a eu envie de
pousser ses enfants vers cet ascenseur
social et lui proposer des études ils
partent sur des bonnes bases
et puis comme ça arrive à de nombreux
nombreux de nos concitoyens vers 45 ans
il ya un gros problème
il ya un gros problème il ya la maladie
il ya la séparation il ya un
licenciement brutal qui vous fait perdre
pied
on en connaît tous dans nos le cancer
qui arrive fréquemment le qui arrive
précocément qui arrivent pour ses
enfants parfois j'ai une situation en
tête qui fait que votre progression et
s'arrête brutalement et donc celui ci
l'a dans le système il faut qu'on en
tienne compte
et ce système là qui dit à salaire
équivalent à salaire équivalent accorde
les mêmes points quel que soit le moment
où ils arrivent
puisse vous permettre d'avoir une
retraite digne nous sommes aussi quelque
chose de protecteur alors oui
effectivement d'un certain nombre de
situations
peut-être que par rapport à l'ancien
système peut-être que ces gens là qui
ont une progression très très régulière
très peut-être qu'ils auront un peu
moins qu'ils avaient avant mais ils
auront de toute façon ils auront de
toute façon une proportion est aimé par
contre que ce qui aurait aurait dû avoir
cette carrière micky par la vie par la
vie quelle qu'elle soit professionnelle
en termes de santé etc ont un blocage eh
ben ils vont être mieux pris en compte
donc cesser ce système là permet de
mieux répondre donc défavorable à ces
amendements
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre
merci on aime la présidente pour une
journée sans questions précises du
député et président vous furent n'est
pas une bonne journée
quelques mots avant pour réaliser des
interlocuteurs monsieur le président
monsieur monsieur monsieur d'arrêt
vilain monsieur coquerel vous faites un
peu quand vous faites des comparaisons
comme si la situation actuelle était
figée et garanties j'ai à plusieurs
reprises rappelé qu' on compte nous
sommes pour nombreux ici rentrer dans la
vie active dans les années 80 90 les
dispositions de la retraite n'était pas
celle d'aujourd'hui on était sur les 37
5 meilleures années
on prenait sa retraite à 60 ans c'était
pas du de l'indexation des salaires
portés aux comptes se faisaient sur le
salaire moyen par tête et pas sur
l'inflation dont vous voyez les choses
ont bien changé donc vous vous expliquer
en fait à nos concitoyens à la
représentation nationale que en fait
tout va rester stable
rassurez-vous nous nous savons au parti
communiste à la france est soumise
nous avons la recette magique pour vous
garantir que rien ne changera et que
100% vos droits de votre situation
restera la même dans le temps bah non
vous n'avez pas sa recette magique le
monde change le monde
je n'existe pas et d'ailleurs de bonnes
volontés de bonne volonté les élus ici
qui ont été présents ont toujours essayé
d'adapter le système de retraite pour
qu'il puisse perdurer et ça le fait que
aujourd'hui quelqu'un comme moi doit
travailler par la réforme touraine plus
que ils le devaient travailler quand je
suis entré dans la vie active en 1990 et
j'en fais pas grief à ceux qui ont voté
cette réforme parce que ils l'ont fait
en réfléchissant pour faire durer notre
système tout comme ceux qui ont décidé à
un moment donné de désindexer les
salaires portés au compte de du revenu
moyen qui fait à l'époque le salaire
moyen est bien quand ils ont décidé et
l'ont fait sans doute en pensant à la
stabilité budgétaire du système tout
comme quand ils pensent aujourd'hui si
je prends l'exemple de monsieur le
député le fur que il serait bon de faire
travailler tout le monde jusqu'à 65 ans
de façon générale il pense que c'est une
bonne idée moi je pense que c'est pas
une bonne idée mais voyez au final au
final la réalité c'est que vous ne
pouvez pas garantir parce que ce serait
une fausse promesse
vous ne pouvez pas garantir à nos
concitoyens et heureusement que vous
pouvez pas le garantir que tout va
rester comme ça figé comme situé dans un
monde inerte où rien ne se passerait
c'est pas le cas et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut prendre les choses à bras le corps
c'est ce que fait cette majorité en
proposant un vrai pacte social à rénover
reconstruit avec ses citoyens avec une
solidarité intergénérationnelle qui va
vivre dans le temps alors monsieur le
député le fur vous prenez des cas
particuliers très précis et moi j'aime
bien les cas très précis et puis ils
sont le fond vous avez raison de vouloir
valoriser la dynamique d'ascenseur
social
la progression parce que d'ailleurs je
crois que le rapporteur turcot elle
avait déjà rappelé en début semaine on
nous savons que dans notre pays
malheureusement les cas que vous donnez
sont peu nombreux parce que il faut
plusieurs générations pour évoluer d'une
situation difficile
donc ça veut dire que vous prenez un cas
non seulement très précis mais très
particulier alors moi j'essaye de vous
répondre quand même sur ce cas très
particulier
vous avez un cas type de carrière a sans
doute parce que font que c'est ça que
vous voulez montrer vous voulez en
dehors du cas extrêmement précis
d'infirmières général vous voulez parler
des carrières ascendante vous avez un
très bon exemple dans la page 204 de
notre étude d'impact qui vous parle de
cette carrière ascendante notamment
d'une personne qui va devenir cadres
c'est une
c'est un cas du corps du conseil les
rotations vers quoi donc c'est pas car
j'imagine que tout le monde va pouvoir
se réunir sur ce sujet là puisque c'est
le corps et comme on cite régulièrement
le président a les travaux du cor
j'imagine que lorsque l'étude d'impact
reprend des éléments du corps
ça fait l'unanimité ici et bien en la
matière vous voyez que vous allez voir
que cette personne y gagne des 64 ans
parce que ça traduit bien la réalité de
notre situation
les carrière ascendante vont ils gagner
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
nous allons indexé au dessus de
l'inflation
la valeur du point puisqu'elle va
revenir elle va venir progressivement
sur le revenu moyen par tête et ça c'est
beaucoup plus dynamique y compris dans
la comparaison très spécifique que vous
vouliez faire avec l'infirmière général
puisque vous trouverez un autre exemple
à la page 215 peut-être un peu moins
précis que le vôtre mais qui vous
montrera à la page 115 des études
d'impact que cette personne va y gagner
le tout simplement parce que le salaire
moyen à une évolution bien supérieur à
celui du point d'indicé dans la fonction
publique donc voyez c'est vrai que
spontanément quand on vous écoute on
pourrait se dire ah oui président le fur
a levé un lièvre et puis décompose
l'ensemble des données qu'on regarde
l'ensemble des choses eh bien on se dit
ah bah oui effectivement le gouvernement
a raison et il va effectivement aussi
protéger les carrières à se vendre comme
l'a dit le rapporteur excellent nicolas
turquois alors un mot madame la
présidente sur le débat qui sur le fond
nous occupe depuis ce matin devant ce
dimanche matin qu'il occupe depuis le
début de la semaine puisque nous sommes
toujours sur l'art type 1 et nous
discutons des différents alinéa
des principes généraux alors je dis pas
que ça a pas d'intérêt jeudi que nos
concitoyens que je pense qu'il
souhaiterait plutôt qu'on discute de la
situation de leur retraite future
plutôt du type de droit on va alors
attribuer plus tôt du minimum
contributif mais en fait moi je trouve
que la discussion sémantique entre
est-ce qu'on remplace satisfaisant par
comparables alors que dans comparable
qu'est ce que c'est comparable parce
qu'en fait à chaque fois quand on
réinterroge de gouvernement sur pourquoi
avait démis ce mot là on en mettant un
autre le gouvernement ne le fait pas
mais il pourrait ré interroger le député
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire votre
mot alors alors par action prend
comparable ça veut dire quoi
identique en proportion 2 dans quelles
proportions plus 10% - 20 % plus de sens
voilà on peut faire des débats à n'en
plus finir
mais ce n'est pas ce qu'attendent nos
concitoyens ils attendent qu'on parle de
concret de la façon dont vous mesdames
messieurs député vous avez envie de
discuter avec le gouvernement de ce que
sera leur retraite demain à vivre
merci monsieur mono miss messieurs
sérieux
merci monsieur le ministre la réforme
des retraites c'est aussi l'occasion de
donner des signes forts à l'ensemble des
français sur la société que nous
souhaitons et sur l'évolution de cette
société française alors notre collègue
le furent à une question extrêmement
précise votre réponse ne l'était pas il
y avait quand même quelques éléments
intéressants c'est que vous nous avez
fait une réponse sur une comparaison
pour un départ à 64 ans donc clairement
vous nous dites aujourd'hui on est sur
des calculs avec des départs à 60 4 ans
et + 62 ans et + 63 ans donc c'est un
signe que vous donnez aux français en
tous les cas c'est une information
et puis vous nous avez dit oui mais
cette fameuse personne qui a eu une
carrière ascendante
elle gagnera quand même un peu plus que
si elle ne l'avait pas eu la question de
marc le fur
c'est cette personne qui a une carrière
ascendante
aujourd'hui elle sait qu'elle va
bénéficier d'une retraite supérieure
parce qu'on ne va prendre en compte que
la partie la plus la plus forte
la plus avantageuse de sa carrière et
vous êtes en train de nous dire
qu'effectivement en ayant une carrière
forte
on finira toujours par gagner plus mais
ce que l'on vous dit c'est que cette
personne dans le système actuel
gagnerait plus que ce que vous nous
proposez 7 et vous le reconnaissez donc
vous qu'on vous confirmer bien d'une
part que la personne ira jusqu'à 64 ans
et deuxièmement qu'elle gagnera moins
que dans le système actuel
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que la
vraie question pour ce qui me concerne
c'est pas de savoir s'il y aura un
système de retraites en 2050 tout le
monde le sait la vraie question est
celle que les jeunes ou les posent tous
les jours c'est le niveau des retraites
parce que les jeunes n'y croient plus en
ils ne croient plus au niveau des
retraites suffisant et il s'inquiète de
savoir comment pouvait alors quand on
parle de retraite satisfaisante croyez
que vous donnez un signe extrêmement
négatif aux jeunes générations
demers madame du monde merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre vous
rejoins sur un point au moins
au bout de 18 jours c'est déjà pas mal
ce jeu de ping pong entre nous
effectivement il est absolument
essentiel quand on va être dans le dur
du texte l'emmener sur l'article 1 et
donc il faut aussi qu'on éclaire un peu
les français donc moi ce stade du débat
j'aimerais bien récapituler finalement
ce qu'est cette réforme
cette réforme elle est inutile elle est
bâclée et elle est injuste elle est
inutile parce que les efforts ont déjà
été faits
si le conseil d'état qui le dit le
conseil d'état dit les réformes récentes
ont permis de sécuriser le financement
et s'il ya un problème ça n'est pas un
problème de ressources
c'est un problème de ressources et non
pas de dépenses les ressources avec la
baisse des fonctionnaires avec la
désignation des zones désocialisation
des heures sup et c'est donc elle est
inutile deuxièmement elle est bâclé les
deux ans de consultations la conférence
de financement qui se tient pendant
qu'on travaille ici à l'assemblée
bref le conseil d'état encore lui est
très dur un jeu le site à propos de
l'étude d'impact en particulier qui ne
répondent pas aux exigences
d'objectivité et de sincérité
mais c'est du jamais vu c'est du jamais
vu c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs nous
avons demandé cette commission d'
enquête sur laquelle nous attendons
d'ailleurs des réponses commission d'
enquête sur cette fameuse étude d'impact
je ne reviens pas sur le calendrier
parlementaire délirant nous avons eu une
semaine pour étudier les mille pages de
cette étude d'impact je ne reviens pas
non plus sur la valeur du point
indexé sur un indicateur qui n'existe
pas sur matt combien on va toucher la
retraite va t'elle augmenté vous êtes
incapable de répondre à des questions
aussi simple que ça et enfin elle est
injuste avec ce malus installé sur l'âge
réel de départ à la retraite et non sur
la durée de cotisation ce qui est un
changement absolument majeur en fait il
ya un seul objectif c'est faire des
économies sur le dos des retraités
merci cher collègue monsieur benoit
merci merci madame la présidente
il y a un certain nombre d'amendements
qui m'interpelle moyens au nom de mon
groupe je voulais me positionner
favorablement
c'est l'amendement de stéphane peu le 26
1871 est similaire celui de pierre
dharréville d'ailleurs qui est identique
à celui de même vos nerfs et un certain
nombre de collègues députés du groupe la
république en marche lorsque l'on dit ou
lorsque l'on propose dans la loi que ce
projet donc ce système universel de
retraite fixe un objectif de garantie
d'un niveau de vie digne
chez moi ce mot trouve un écho
particulier je sais qu'il trouve un écho
particulier chez chacun d'entre nous
parce que ce que j'observe c'est qu'en
2020 peut-être plus encore qu'hier nous
concitoyens quelle que soit leur niveau
de vie quelles que soient leurs
possibilités et ça s'est traduit au
moment du mouvement social de l'hiver
dernier ce qu'ils ont besoin c'est de
considération et je pense que cette
notion de dignité dont les auteurs même
vos nerfs stéphane peu pierre
dharréville propose sont les auteurs eh
bien je trouve que c'est une belle
proposition monsieur le ministre
monsieur rapporteur moi je serai fier ce
matin ce dimanche matin que nous
écrivions dans ce texte de loi que nous
remplacions le mot satisfaisant par
digne parce que lorsque l'on parle des
retraites
on parle de l'avenir on parle du futur
on parle de la solidarité entre les
générations et que cela se passe dans la
dignité
je trouve que c'est quelque chose de
essentiels dont je soutiens cet
amendement avec l'ensemble de mes
collègues udi agir indépendamment
merci chers collègues que monsieur bell
et non oui quelque peu en écho de mon
ami thierry benoit et pour une réponse à
nos camarades de la gauche
moi je suis assez d'accord je suis
d'accord avec vous sur le principe
monsieur peu et sur le fond
effectivement la dignité c'est quelque
chose que tout le monde entend on est on
est assez d'accord
après visiblement il ya quand même des
petits problèmes logistiques
mais c'est un autre sujet mais pourquoi
je vous dis que je suis d'accord avec
vous c'est parce que c'est justement
pour ça aussi que nous faisons cette
réforme
cette réforme elle va donner des droits
à ce qu'ils soient ceux dont vous avez
parlé aujourd'hui vous avez parlé de
retraités dans leur voiture c'est quoi
un retraité dans sa voiture aujourd'hui
c'est quoi quelqu'un qui a travaillé
toute sa vie et qui se retrouve à avoir
une pension insuffisante pour payer un
loyer pour pour pour vivre oui quoi qui
pardon mais quoi l'ensemble du système
vous avez raison c'est qui cette
personne là
c'est un homme ou une femme qui a eu une
part qu un parcours difficile qui a
commencé parfois un premier métier et
pour une raison x ou y
parfois la pénibilité parfois l'accident
de travail et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
travailler sur le fond de la pénibilité
dans la prévention on en a déjà parlé et
c'est un sujet qu'on porte au modem il a
eu une rupture de carrière après cette
rupture de carrière il a galéré il a eu
des petits il a eu des petits boulots il
a parfois fait d'équidés trimestre
incomplet souvent il a fait des
trimestres incomplet souvent il n'a pas
travaillé une année il a il était au
chômage et toutes ces essais ce sont ces
personnes là qui vont avoir des droits
nouveaux et notre notre notre régie
notre nouveau régime
il va favoriser ces personnes là et vous
critiquez beaucoup notre faim d'autres
ce pas le nôtre
l'étude d'impact du conseil d'état mais
l'étude d'impact du conseil d'état elles
elles le disent elle le dit oui l'avis
du conseil d'état entre put notre étude
d'un maillet sein de poursuivre excusez
moi est censé vous avez raison oui mais
les deux disent que justement sur ces
parcours là sur ces parcours là les le
la situation avant sera largement
donc moi je suis d'accord si vous voulez
qu'on discute sur la qualité compte mais
allons sur du rock du droit réel et
allons sur une réalité pour ces
travailleurs qui aujourd'hui ne l'ont
pas merci monsieur peu non merci
dans cet article un qui est une des clés
un article de principe et kate un
principe de cadrage de la loi vaut mieux
avoir les bons mots pour dire les choses
satisfaisant excusez moi c'est un terme
qui se réfère à rien la dignité
c'est un texte qui se réfère à la
déclaration des droits de l'homme de
1948 donc autant se référer après ça ne
ça ne purge pas le débat qu'on aura plus
tard dans l'examen de la loi pour savoir
derrière le mot dignité comment on
traduit sa concrètement dans la loi mais
les mots sont importants et ce n'est pas
la même chose
regard des textes fondateurs de notre
république de parler de dignité au lieu
de terme satisfaisant qui lui ne se
réfère à rien du tout et ne veut pas
dire grand chose ça c'est la première et
la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
c'est faire écho à ce qu'a dit marc le
fur
parce que très franchement je je je vous
le dis on c'est ça mais beaucoup revenue
aussi dans ma circonscription
la question de la reconnaissance de la
progression dans le travail du mérite de
l'effort et donc l'ouvrier qui devient
contremaître et qui devient cadre mais
moi on est venu me voir j'ai des
exemples très précis à l'état une
couturière qui est devenu chef d'atelier
qui aujourd'hui à la confiance de son
patron pour tenir en responsabilité une
boutique le gac a démarré guichetier à
la banque qui est devenu chef de bureau
et qui est maintenant directeur d'agencé
je peux vous en citer le maçon qui est
devenu ensuite coffreur qui aujourd'hui
conducteur de travaux et par avance et
en prenant en compte les 25 meilleures
années
ce mérite cette progression c'était fort
était considérée et aujourd'hui ça a été
d'ailleurs reconnu par le rapporteur
le fait de prendre toute la durée de la
vie c'est le découragement du mérite de
l'effort de la progression sociale
oui dans ce débat ce qui est assez
pénible c'est que en fait en réalité
vous étiez toujours nous faire prendre
des vessies pour des lanternes monsieur
pourquoi je vous ai entendu sur cette
question d'une carrière complète
vous pouvez dire ce que vous voulez vous
pouvez parler de progression fulgurante
qui s'arrête dans les faits un calcul
sur une carrière complète sera toujours
inférieure à une calcul sur les 25
meilleures années
pouvez vous y prendre comme vous voulez
donc arretez nous raconter des fables
parce qu'au moins on pourrait avoir un
débat plus intéressant sur ce que vous
comptez faire deuxième chose
monsieur le ministre vous dit que le
monde change bon alors le mode change
c'est pas d'obsèques machina a cédé
politique ils font changer et des
politiques iep lille trentaine d'années
effectivement vous avez raison vise à
faire en sorte que les revenus du
travail baisse proportionnellement par
rapport à la richesse produite au faveur
des revenus du capital
et c'est au nom de sa queue
notamment sur les retraites on est passé
de 37 et demi à 40 ans etc etc on est
passé des vins des dix meilleures années
aux 25 meilleures années
mais il ya quand même une différence
même si pas pour ma part je regrette ces
réformes c'est que jusqu'à maintenant il
y avait la priorité qui était donnée en
fonction de prestations définies au fait
qu' on règle les pensions dans le
système que vous allez mettre en place
celle inverse c'est à dire qu'avec la
règle d'or ce n'est plus le niveau des
pensions qui sera garanti mais les
équilibres financiers du système avec la
loi pluriannuelle que vous allez voter
et qui va encadrer en réalité justement
les pensions et l'âge déquilibre à
laquelle on pourra partir donc en
réalité ça sera toujours glissant mois
chaque année par exemple je pense que
beaucoup de collègues le reçoivent ici
on reçoit le décompte on nous dit
at-elle ad vous pouvez partir avec tes
l'argent dans le système que vous avez
mis en place ça sera terminé parce que
ça va dépendre d'un vote à l'assemblée
qui va définir les prestations
financières et de ses prestations
financières découleront les pensions les
niveau des pensions et je vais vous dire
je termine juste peuple ans si vous
aviez fait ça entre 2008 et 2012 au
moment où les pensions de retraite ont
permis avec d'autres tubes à d'autres
mécanismes de solidarité nationale que
l'économie ne plonge pas parce que le
marché privé était devenue atone
eh bien je vais vous dire non seulement
il y aurait eu plus de travailleurs
pauvres mais économiquement ça aurait
été une catastrophe
merci cher collègue madame niveau merci
madame la présidente je pense qu'on
regarde des départs on peut au moins
tout cet accord sur ces bancs tous sans
exception pour reconnaître la dignité de
l'homme je pense que ça nous pose aucun
problème et c'est tant mieux
en revanche aujourd'hui en tous les cas
dans le code de la sécurité sociale et
dans la charte sociale européenne le
terme de référence aujourd'hui est
satisfaisant pour en revenir à
l'amendement lorsque vous dites qu
effectivement dans votre amendement vous
remplacer les termes un niveau de vie
satisfaisant par un niveau de vie des
retraités comparable à celui des actifs
à mon avis vous manqué d'ambition car
aujourd'hui déjà il est supérieur de 6
points à celui des actifs et leur niveau
de pauvreté est deux fois moins élevé
que celui des actifs
et c'est tant mieux et c'est bien ce que
veut nous voulons et garder et amélioré
en mettant en place
annie
de vie qui permettent d'attribuer 85% du
smig à tous les retraités en 2037
mais dès 2022 on veut octroyer
effectivement 1000 euros parce que c'est
un minimum vraiment incontournable donc
oui nous voulons maintenir et améliorer
le niveau de vie des retraités
je remercie ses chers collègues à la
demande de la présence de commissions la
séance est suspendue pour cinq minutes
un jeu
[Musique]
la séance est reprise
madame du monde pour un rappel au
règlement merci madame la présidente
oui nous nous étonnons un petit peu
qu'après la discussion qui a eu lieu
cette nuit sur la façon avec laquelle il
serait répondu à l'intervention du
président de la république au salon de
l'agriculture qui avait déclaré qu'il
était impossible
pardon sur la base de l'article 145 le
président a déclaré qu'il était
impossible de revaloriser les retraites
agricoles actuels ça coûterait un
milliard cent millions
vous reconnaîtrez que c'est pas
forcément grand chose à côté des caps
milliards qui vont être économisés par
ceux qui gagnent plus de 120000 euros
par an et donc il a été évoqué la
nomination on n'a pas bien compris soit
d'un parlementaire en mission soit d'une
mission parlant parlementaire moi je
voudrais à bahia un rapport direct
il est dans le fait que nous nous
souhaitons que le travail se fasse au
parlement qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
député en mission c'est un député qui
est nommée par le gouvernement pour un
temps maximum 6 mois aux ordres si on
veut je vous donne quelques exemples
d'abord je voudrais vous informer que
cette hui cette législature est celle où
on fait sauter la banque en termes de
nombre de députés en mission puisqu'il y
en a déjà 89 qui ont été nommés depuis
le début de la législature
ce qui était un record sow
et quand on rend les sujets qui sont des
outils si chers collègues attendent et
merci présidente lure
je conclus les sujets évoqués dans
lequel genre calme que vous réclamez
tous en particulier le mieux sur le
présent le fur un rappel au règlement
pour le président mignola
le nom mais sur la base de l'article 95
je pense que c'était l'article qu'elle
voulait faire référence notre collègue
du monde donc je lui indique au passage
je voudrais lel 145 donc on est 95 et
145 et simplement pour indiquer deux
choses la première
s'il ya autant de parlementaires en
mission aujourd'hui sur des missions qui
sont confiées par le gouvernement c'est
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
problèmes dans ce pays et c'est
probablement pour ça que cette majorité
est là ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose
croyez bien que les parlementaires sont
indépendants moi je connais quelques
personnes dans le groupe que j'ai
l'honneur de présider qui sont jaloux tu
cette indépendance et qui une fois la
mission confiée sont tout à fait
capables de faire valoir les intérêts de
la mission pour lesquels ils ont été
diligentées troisième élément sûr
puisque vous voulez y revenir
apparemment on était sur un débat très
important sur satisfaisant et digne mais
puisque vous voulez revenir à la
discussion de cette nuit c'est avec
plaisir
moi je me suis efforcé mais probablement
les cheveux toute façon et pas
suffisamment claire à cette tribune
lundi après-midi sur la question des
retraités d'aujourd'hui nous étudier un
texte pour les retraités de demain
s'agissant des retraités agricoles
commerçants et artisans donc les
retraités d'aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas
faire partie de ce texte pour autant la
majorité sous l'impulsion de très
nombreux députés ont demandé au
gouvernement que la question des
retraités d'aujourd'hui puissent être
réglés elle relève du plfss
et donc nous avons besoin qu'une mission
soient confiées et j'ai proposé au
premier ministre que ce soit les deux
rapporteurs généraux du plfss de
l'assemblée du sénat qui travaille pour
objectiver le sujet lycée les personnes
concernées évalué budgétairement
proposer un calendrier d'application
excusez du peu pendant des années sauf à
une semaine des élections législatives
vous n'étiez jamais intervenu
nous nous le faisons
merci chers collègues monsieur le
président vigier persimmon à la prudence
le ministre messieurs les ministres
je pense que les mots ont un sens et
hier on a eu un bon moment dans cet
hémicycle lorsqu'on a su dans les grands
principes de cette réforme des retraites
faire en sorte que et bien la notion de
handicap partagés sur tous ces bancs
puis s'est intégrée dans les grands
objectifs parce qu'en fait si on peut
regretter qu'on soit pas derrière les
autres articles mais nous sommes là pour
aller au bout du chemin moi je préconise
qu'on y aille au bout du chemin
étudier tous les articles monsieur le
ministre lorsqu on exprime que une
retraite avec le mot digne derrière me
semble-t-il
il ya une signification forte une portée
aux mots saluons n'a pas oublié ses
retraités qui ont vu malheureusement